[Music]
and he was i was really good i was like
i thought oh you know what i think i
could have done a better job than he did
clap
piss me off
happy tuesday my tuesday friends
well i don't know about you but i'm
starving i bet you were wondering does
the new mayor of new york city eat a
plant-based centered life
i eat a plant-based scented life
some people want to call me vegan vegans
eat oreos and they drink coca-cola i
don't
i guess he does but what else does he do
i eat a plant-based centered life
and those who are the food police for me
they can food police all the time i ate
a plant-based centered life
i eat a plant-based centric life and i'm
not going down that hold on hold on hold
on please don't do that yelling out
stuff with me i don't do it to you don't
do it to me i wonder if he eats a
plant-based centered life
anything else you'd like to add mr mayor
i did plants based scented life and i'm
not going down this rabbit hole of what
do you eat if you eat cake and it has
eggs in it that you analyze it i'm not
doing that the more plant-based you eat
the better and healthier you are that is
my question to those who are following
me around in restaurants wondering what
i'm ordering listen i'm not doing that
that's noise to me i gotta get new
yorkers to eat a plant-based scented
life i'm thinking this guy really feels
strongly
about a plant-based centered life well
as strong as someone lacking in protein
can be
god i wish i felt as strongly about
anything as he feels about plant-based
centered life well no this show is my
plant-based centered life
but i guess he wants all new yorkers to
eat the same way half of us already do i
think they're called edibles
but maybe i think there are bigger
health priorities than this like not
getting murdered there's nothing you can
do better for your health than not
getting dead
also not getting robbed raped or beaten
all those trump a steady diet of bean
curd and soy burgers you know i'm happy
to eat plants once in a while but first
just don't turn me into a meal for worms
of course it's not adam's fault the
reporters asked i'd call these softball
questions but hitting a bull's ass with
a base fiddle would be more difficult
but it's his priority he already made
friday vegan lunch day at nyc schools
otherwise known as bring your own burger
king day
it's always about priorities what
leaders and the media see is threats
versus the threats you actually face
crime is certainly up there for sure but
today the legacy media has anointed the
real danger and it's not murderers or
rapists
it's those evil canadian truckers
because nothing says sedition like
beeping your horn
absolutely remarkable i mean just think
of the language i know it sounds
familiar to you right a threat to
democracy an insurrection sedition
cnn even after jeff zucker is gone the
stench of the smear tactic still lingers
the network is like walking into a men's
room that stelter is walking out of
of course this fiction has less
fatalities than a set visit with alec
baldwin and there's no evidence offered
by these people but as
expected they all fall in line like
canadian geese heading south for the
winter
the police chief saying his city is
under siege calling the demonstrations a
nationwide insurrection the movement is
being called an insurrection by some
paralyzing the canadian capital those
with the so-called freedom convoy say
they're staying put it's
a
cult
yes it is
it's so hard to be concerned when we
still haven't captured those terrorists
at school board meetings
and canada's pm chimes in proving that
the media and the left always share the
same lice ridden bed
people of ottawa don't deserve to be
harassed in their own neighborhoods
they don't deserve to be confronted with
the inherent violence of a swastika
flying on a street corner
or a confederate flag
are the insults
and jeers
just because they're wearing a mask
i'd call them a clown but clowns wear
white face
so what's the reason for this well
trudeau was born with a silver spoon in
his mouth and up his ass the virtue
signaling skunk hates the working class
but also the leggy legacy media is
scared the leggy media
the convoy is basically a bunch of joe
rogans they aren't buying what the media
is selling so the media needs to create
false narratives in which they are the
good guys and the average citizen who no
longer listens to them well they're the
bad guys they're like a delinquent
babysitter who blames the kids for the
grease fire in the kitchen or the
cigarette burns on the sofa
remember cnn once cast chris cuomo as
the good guy
now they cast him as the bad guy the
demonizing depends on how it protects
their butts so they demonize the so far
so peaceful truckers it's easy to do
they appear whiter than the nhl all-star
game so i guess that immediately makes
them nazis however much of these critics
defended the riots and arson that spread
across the country back in 2020 they
called the violence peaceful now they
call the peaceful violent even today
it's still nothing to see there with
those riots even when they're the actual
nothing
is murder
senator tom cotton is demanding answers
regarding the lenient prison sentence of
a man convicted of burning down a pawn
shop in minneapolis that killed a man
inside during the fl the george floyd
riots he was given a light sentence
apparently because the killing was
committed during the riots i mean
protests
under merit garland equal justice under
the law is deader than that victim of
the arson attack
murder someone in a media approved riot
you get sympathy but if you're some
trucker who's never committed a crime
non-violent civil disobedience is added
to the ever-expanding definition of
insurrection you see the game as long as
the left-wing media is losing the war
over ideas they must resort to smearing
no wonder they believe justice millet
it's right out of their playbook
meanwhile they protect the side iran
politically even if that side ends up
actually killing people
the white house gets attacked by the
left and there's nothing to see here
cities attacked by the left for weeks or
months on end nothing to see there a few
hour riot at the capitol worse than 9
11.
and remember as long as you have parrots
willing to play along the lie will
always continue
am i hearing you right congressman you
fear potentially there could be a civil
war here in the united states
i do and i and a year ago i would have
said no not a chance our basic survival
is at stake the basic survival of this
democracy wow
yeah right looks like cnn has found
their chris cuomo replacement i hope
he's got a giant q-tip
anyway i wonder what mayor adam's
thinking about
i eat a plant-based scented life
some people want to call me vegan vegans
eat oreos and they drink coca-cola i
don't oh they gotta put that in the song
let's welcome tonight's guest
his clothes cause moths to lose their
appetite founder of theloftusparty.com
michael lofton
he's like fluorescent lighting so bright
that it makes most people look bad
former white house national security
council aide cash patel
she followed dry january with face down
february fox news contributor cat tip
and he changes weather patterns simply
by flexing my massive sidekick in the
nwa world television champion
tyrus so mr loftus have you been
following this trucker convoy from the
shelter you're staying at mom
they took away our tv
yeah you all you know it's horrible
sometimes you can't have nice things you
can't no yeah i've been following the
trucker thing bigly yes that has been
awesome i love it i love when the
protest is parking yeah right they don't
even have to hold signs and walk around
they're just like
put it in park we're changing the world
and what a great what a great thing i
couldn't support them more and they have
all the leverage they deliver the food
yeah if you think about it like if
nintendo goes on strike whatever i'm
gonna hit up the xbox the electricity
people go whatever sun's coming up we
need the food people i need electricity
really do you i guess not more than food
yeah and that's what i love about
trudeau he's like we're going to lock
them up eh that's like kicking that's
like asking the waiter where is my
entree and then not letting him leave
the table yeah that's a good interesting
analogy thank you you know um would you
feel differently if this were happening
in new york city and you couldn't get to
where you wanted to go
uh nah no no i'd just be like whatevs
honk honk freedom baby
what happened to him yeah i'll tell you
what happened to me i decided to live i
decided to start living a plant-based
life
that's what i was enlightened that was
the best ever like
how long did he talk about that
he would take 45 minutes saying that
he's not going there it's brilliant
eisen i'm not going there i i will not
he feels strongly about i wish he felt
that strongly about crime cash but uh
you could talk about whatever you want
you want to talk about the convoy i what
i noticed is that they're bad appling
the convoy like they try to find the
very worst element of it and then and
then
just paint the broad stroke for
everything like they see a flag
confederate flags and they go everybody
there's a nazi that's i call that bad
appling
that's a good one i think it's i mean
you know this being a guy you know brown
guy that the prime minister of canada
who is caught brown facing repeatedly
the massive indian canadian population
right and now you're forcing me to stare
at him across the way here standing next
to the black mayor of new york city like
yes you guys are the you know rescuers
of democracy and racial diversity
so i kind of hate him yeah
but i like the truckers they're cool
mm-hmm and gofundme sucks yeah so they
moved all the money over to something go
send me i think that's what give someone
give send go yeah that's pretty cool
it's not they're still gonna get screwed
oh really i mean it's a payment
processing issue but that's why i
started my company but that's a story
for another day ah interesting we'll
have to talk afterwards yeah all right
tyrus all right gut-felt plant-based or
truck-based you know well both but i
think the the
truck the truckers are due handling it a
lot better than the mayor i think the
brother's in trouble he couldn't get
through dinner at new york yeah he's
arguing about what he eats and when you
say i'm not going down the rabbit hole
yes and you keep talking
bro you're in the rabbit hole you're
deep yeah you ca um you can't see elmer
fudd anymore yeah
do you think do you think because he's
eating so much so many plants he thinks
he's a rabbit
no i just i this is i don't know him
well enough to really judge him i just
you know as a former police officer and
stuff i'm assuming that he's going to be
tough on crime for the best of his
ability but
i just don't think he's realized what
he's taking on with the job and he's not
looking at the the lay of the land the
last thing the american people want
right now is someone telling them what
to do we've literally had to deal with
it for the last two and a half years we
don't need someone else telling us what
to eat and just real quick but it really
depends on your dna what's best for you
whether it's protein plants everyone's
different you get a little test and they
tell you what's good for you not good
for you so for him to try to push his
his diet is just it's a really bad idea
given the circumstance we don't want any
more
pushed ideas from government we would
like just quiet solutions he sounds like
somebody that really really into a band
and is demanding that you listen to this
one song
you need to listen to this one song it's
gonna blow your mind i swear to god
that's how he is about plant based and
it doesn't blow your mind it doesn't
everybody's like this really sucks this
just sucks
meanwhile he's crying but the one thing
i believe is that he doesn't drink
coca-cola because he called it coca-cola
i haven't heard that since my
grandmother was like would you like a
coca-cola
i found that so charming i don't drink
coca-cola well neither do we we drink
coke
so kat um
i don't know what's up the vegan the
vegan diet does that does that is that
of interest to you or the truckers
uh i guess
chalkers are always going to be more
interested in the vegan diet yes
i tried to find a trucker tonight who
was on a vegan diet none exist no i
doubt it
yeah well justin should know his whole
thing that he was so mad at these
truckers because they're shutting down
the economy he says it's like okay so
it's only okay when you do it yeah like
exactly it's like are you mad that
they're copying you because otherwise
you have no right to be upset and also
this whole thing really negates what he
said and keeps trying to say which is
just a fringe minority because if it was
just a french minority it wouldn't be
such a big issue it wouldn't matter
right it's that it is so many people who
feel this way that they're worried about
getting supplies so i mean he's tried
everything but listening but listening
might be might be a good move yeah you
were once in a fringe minority
absolutely i seem to remember that do
you remember him wearing fringe oh i'll
i'll wear fringe like like i'm in the
road show of oklahoma yeah really no
idea what that means because i've only
ever seen you wear that jacket yes
i'm just curious is the confederate flag
a big thing in
canada know huge thing i've never and i
love i've been there a lot and i never
saw and i love you i've ever heard of
yee-haw or
whoever
this is an insurrection we're headed
towards civil war you know who says that
a lot and who's worried about a lot the
dudes who know they're gonna lose you
like because if you if you do the like
okay so what would the teams be we have
tucker we have like truckers
construction workers small business and
they have some kid who'd like um i'm not
going to shoot my gun unless you call me
zimzer
i think i know who's going to win zimzer
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else